hello everyone I hope you're all having
a wonderful Saturday and hopefully this
game will make it even greater it's a
game from around 8:00 between a josé
raúl capablanca and under lilienthal now
you've seen a cup of Blanca versus both
unique it was in round 7 botanique
really had capablanca on the attack he
had that Queen a5 move which would
completely shatter Blancas defenses but
he went for a flashy variation and then
capablanca won in the end
so now couple Lanka is in the lead in
the tournament and now he has the white
pieces but he is up against underlay
Lilienthal definitely not gonna be an
easy game it's a very nice slow
maneuvering game that again really shows
a couple bankers capabilities in the end
game
so before we check it out here we have a
nice photo for the photo challenge who
are the two players playing the game
here of course you get one point for
each player so best of luck to everyone
now let's see the game we have a knight
to f3 d5 c4 and c6 so the English
opening we have b3 rush up to f5 and
Bishop to b2 e6 we have g3 and Knight to
f6 better up to g2 both bishops are now
Fiat Knight bd7
we have castles by capablanca and h6 d3
Bishop to e7 Knight bTW - we have
castles rock c1 and now a five we have a
three rook to e8 and now you really have
to figure out how to proceed here with
the white pieces here kappa blanka plays
rook to c2 seems like a weird move
you know why put your rook somewhere
where this bishop could attack it at
some point but he actually wants to
bring his Queen over to a1 so he can
pressure with this Queen battery as the
g7 pawn is undefended so a very nice
idea
we have Bushra back to h7 Queen to 8:1
now and now but back to a fate so the
bishop will now defend the g7 pawn
tonight can now move rook e1
Queen to b6 and now bunch of to h3
simply you know increasing the activity
of the light square bishop we have
Bishop to c5 now that Capablanca tried
to activate his rook we a via rook to
you
he left the F DuPont undefended so now
Bishop to c5 immediately threatens to
capture an f2 so a couple Blanca has to
go back it wasn't the greatest time to
activate the rook and we have route back
to f1 and hear Lilienthal plays the
bishop back he knows a couple Anka just
defeated Mikhail Botvinnik and maybe he
would be interested in a draw a
repetition here but not really we have
looked back to see one we have looked
back a roof to d8 and the now comes rook
F 2 e1 again a couple monka tries to
activate the rook and again Bishop to c5
Lilienthal does not allow it
so Cooper Blanco has to play the rook
back rook to f1 and now push it back to
f8 again Lilienthal offers a repetition
push it back to G - ok we have Bishop to
d6 and now comes nice the e5 and here
Andre accepts a series of exchanges the
Knight captures the Bishop captures
knife captures and Queen captures now
couple long casts queen is very nicely
placed on e5 so you do have to kick it
away from there in 97 we have Queen back
to b2 and now Knight back to f6 again a
lilienthal offers a repetition here b4
and here a very interesting moment in
the game lilienthal captures a capture
some before and now I'm pretty sure I
don't know if I played this I would play
a pawn captures because okay then if
rook comes the other book will also
counter the a file but mainly because if
if you capture with the Queen which was
played in the game your pawn structure
is now ruined and black does not have to
trade Queens black can go Queen a7 wrote
Oh Queen c7
but for some reason kappa blanka
captured Queen before can't really
figure out why would he do this
and for some reason illusion thought did
accepted the Queen it would the Queen
trade so he didn't go play Queen a7
Queen c7 rather he picked up the Queen
and then pawn captures on before now
improving the pawn structure so maybe
probably even thought that okay it's a
completely drawn position doesn't really
matter I don't want to push with the
black pieces against Capablanca could be
one of the reasons but a very
interesting choice but okay rook to e8
I'm going for controlling the a file
rook to e1
countering the rock on i-89 37 and now
nice to the b3 we have King to f8 you
have to bring your King into the game
rook to a5 now preparing rock a1 so
first pawn capture some c4 pawn captures
and c4 and the Knights to b6 now rook
captures an eight rook captures and now
Knight to a5 attacking the b7 pawn now
you have to protect the b7 pawn or maybe
maybe you could give it up
so as the knight is also guarding the c4
pawn but okay you could play rook to b8
Lilienthal decides to play rook to a7
here a couple of money so he goes look
to D 1 as now a Lilienthal after playing
rook to a7 left control of the last rank
and here you have a couple of ways to
continue this position you could push g5
if you want to bring your King into the
game you could play King to e7 a lot of
ideas here but one more move you cannot
make is exactly the one Lilienthal made
he played King 28 and he missed kappa
Blancas next move but you are more than
welcome to pause the video here and
figure out a couple Blancas next move as
and prove that a king 28 is is in fact a
blunder so I will get a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent and game player and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
here kappa blanka played Knight captures
on b7 of course it seems pretty obvious
now if rook captures Bishop captures on
c6 checks the king wins the rook and
okay in the game rope capture some b7
was played Knight captures and c4 is
another idea
maybe capturing on c4 and then allowing
Bishop captures here and then white
would be left with this very strong
passed pawn and after King moves so
white has white has a you know a lot of
options either attack the knight it went
rolling the D foul or simply pulled upon
but after this night to be 7 move rook
captures on b7 was played by Lily until
he tried a different idea we have Bishop
captures with check and now roadblocks
so his idea was okay now my Knight is
guarding the roof so I will give up the
exchange but here kappa blanka played
see file of course he wants to kick away
the night
now we have King to e7 now of course if
you capture the night then you get a
roof captures here so you do have to
capture it Bishop captures was played
Knight captures on d7 and now c6
so now lilienthal has two pieces for the
rook but the two connected passed pawns
will will prove to be very hard to deal
with Knight b6 and now comes c7 we have
Bishop to f5 you have to activate the
bishop and control the see a square
preparing to push a 5 here rope to d8
preparing to bring the Queen into the
game and now e5 only move guarding the
c8 where we have rook to b8 attacking
the knight Knight to c8 and now comes a
point the other pass pawn is being
pushed forward King D 6 and now b6 and
here knife to e7
if you try something like king c6 then e
4 is coming
if you captured upon then of course you
lose the night here so after Bishop d7
then comes b7 and now after we capture
here simply Queen captures and that's
the rook will prove to be stronger than
the bishop so after b6 we have Knight to
e7
we have rook the rook to f8 Bishop to
see it now blocking b7 rook captures on
f7 ok
now black will be able to get rid of
those pawns but now the pawns of the
Condor King side will fall we have rook
captures g7 Knight captures b6 rook to
h6 Knight to d5 rope captors and h6 with
check King c7 grabbing the other pawn
and E for now so still Lilienthal has
two pieces for the rook but Capablanca
is now up three points two of those
bones are connected passed pawns and the
five point is a very weak pawn as it is
on a dark square xi has a light square
Bishop and the King is cut off from the
game 97 we have f3
we have King King d7 h 4 now in gate
rook to f6 Knight to g8 and here comes
Rock to c6 and it was in this position
that under
lilienthal resigned at the game what if
you resigned well there's really nothing
to do here the King has a pretty nice
way of entering the game rook c5
followed by rook captures on e5
there's really no good way to stop this
and then it's simply for connected
passports that's unplayable so that's
that's the game around eight of the very
strong Moscow international tournament
of 1936 after beating Botvinnik then
Capablanca defeats under lilienthal and
so far the tournament is really really
going great for him so we're gonna check
out a couple of more games from this
tournament I do hope you are enjoying
the coverage as it is you know a
historically important tournament the
last had the last international
tournament in Moscow that was organised
by Sri Lanka so yeah that's the game I
would like to thank better than gay love
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it and I
really want to thank everyone for
joining the stream yesterday was really
insane over two thousand people at the
same time during live and of course I
would like to thank all five thousand
and 100 of you that joined the
tournament the tournament for those of
you who weren't able to follow it was
won by a grandmaster Andrew tank also
known as the penguin and not only that
he wanted with a 100% berserk rate so
that's completely insane and second
place was won by Iranian grandmaster ali
reza furious oh and place number three i
was won by a player who I still don't
know who it is but I will notify as soon
as fight I find out his identity so him
I will put you know some other
information about who the winners of the
giveaway were you can check out the the
tournament I will also put a link to
delete chess tournament and also I will
put a link to the to the video of the
entire stream lasting four hours so you
can check it out if you want so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with another
interesting video now I'm about to go
have a nice celebration party and we're
gonna have some cake some craft beer and
you know some some fun so thank you all
and have an excellent Saturday